Speaker 1: You're not going to believe this
next clip. This this is just unbelievable.
I expected that it would happen, but I didn't know
that it would be. John Barrasso. Last week, during
a whacked interview with Sean HANNITY, Donald
Trump talked about telepathic declassification
of documents. Donald Trump said during his
interview with Sean HANNITY that as president,
he could think about declassifying a document and
that declassified the document. Don't believe me,
you don't have to. Here's the video.
Speaker 2: To end it. You know,
there's different people say
different things. But as I said,
it doesn't have to be. If you're the president
of the United States, you can declassify just by
saying it's declassified, even by thinking
about it because you're sending it to Mar
a Lago or to wherever you're sending it.
Speaker 1: There it is. Just by thinking
about declassification, you can declassify
documents. This is absolutely sickening.
Insane. Absurd. Comical in some weird way.
Well, Republican Senator John Barrasso went
on ABC's This Week with George STEPHANOPOULOS
yesterday. STEPHANOPOULOS rhetorically asks him
about telepathic declassification. And
Barrasso doesn't even say that. That's
absurd. Look at this. This is unbelievable.
Speaker 2: Oh, I want to ask you about the
investigation of Donald Trump's handling of
classified information, even though his lawyers
are providing no evidence that he declassified
the documents that Trump said this week,
that as president, he could declassified documents
by thinking about it. Do you agree with that?
I've not heard that one before, George, like I
tell you. In terms of national security folks.
Speaker 1: He's answering it like it's a real
question. He's answering it like it's a real
thing. Telepathic declassification.
Speaker 2: He means
we have to always use extreme caution. I'm on
the Foreign Relations Committee. We deal with
classified information all of the time.
Speaker 1: And really. And have you ever
on that Foreign Relations Committee dealt with
the telepathic declassification of documents.
Speaker 2: Or always very careful. I
don't know what a what anything about
the rules for when a president declassified.
Speaker 1: I mean, maybe the rules allow
telepathic declassification. Maybe they don't.
Speaker 2: Documents and information. What I
do know is what I'd like to see from a
Senate standpoint is I'd like to see the
Department of Justice come to us and show us in
a classified setting what the information is,
what they've done. I thought this was a raid at
the former president's home.
Speaker 1: And now you'll see.
STEPHANOPOULOS realize that Barroso's lost
the plot and try to get them back on track
by saying, Senator, what I said is absurd.
Speaker 2: Never seen anything like that before,
clearly, and has become critical. So I want to
get a briefing so that we can then be informed
to see what actually happened here. Now,
that was a rhetorical question. You know,
that a president can't declassified documents
by thinking about it. Why can't you say so?
Well, I don't think a president can declassify
documents by saying so by thinking about it.
Speaker 1: Why does it? By saying so? No. By. By
thinking about it. What is wrong with this guy?
Is this guy so under the thumb of Trumpism that he
can't just come out and say, Judge, of course you
can't think about documents and declassify them.
Of course. Of course. That first and foremost,
I also am concerned about how the search warrant
was approved. Oh, okay. Well, now we have a
conversation to talk about, but 60 seconds about.
Well, listen, you know, we should figure out what
the documents are and then determine what are
the methods we're talking about telepathically
declassified, declassified documents here. Oh,
you know, you can't do that. Know that's true. I
guess you can't do that. These people are off the
deep end. And if you think this is bad, just wait
until you see what I have. Coming up after the
break. Remember, you can find all of these clips
that we play on the show on our Instagram
search The David Pakman Show on Instagram